اعلن جهاز وامن الدوله الفيدراليه الروسيه
انه احبط محاوله اوكرانيه لضرب خط انابيب
السيل الجنوبي الذي يمد تركيا واوروبا
بالطاقه وقال بيان صدر من الجهاز ان
المواطنين روز طالعين في التحضير للعمليه
قد اعتقلوا وتمت مصادره اربعه الغام
مغناطيسيه واربعه كيلو غرامات من المواد
المتفجره واموالا ووسائل الاتصال كانت
بحوزتهم
تخريبيه تابعه للاجهزه الاوكانيه الخاصه
مدير مكتب الجزيره زور شاورما التفاصيل عن
ما اعلن هو جهاز امن الدوله الروسيه زاور
عبد القادر
بيان جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي تحدث عن
رصد مكالمات بين المعتقلين ومواطنين رؤوس
مع احد ضباط الاجهزه الخاصه الاوكرانيه
التي تناولت او تضمنت كثير من المعطيات
همم بما فيها ذلك بما فيها تلك المتعلقه
بخطه التفجير المزعومه وايضا مكان التفجير
الذي بحسب جهاز من الدوله كان من المفترض
ان يكون في احدى المناطق
بمقاطعه فولغوغراد لها توضيح عبد القادر
خط مورد ستريم همم او عفو كريم او خطا
التيار الجنوبي هو مشروع همم بدا قبل عشر
سنوات تقريبا وكانت روسيا ستنقل به الغاز
تحت البحر الاسود الى بلغاري ولكن تحت
الضغوط على الغربيه همم تخلت بلغاري عن
هذا المشروع وتوجهت روسيا حينها الى تركيا
وتم تنفيذ ما يعرف بخطا السيل التركي او
تركي ستريم عندما نتحدث عن السيل الجنوبي
هو عباره عن منظومه انابيب تنقل الغاز
بالمناطق مختلفه من روسيا الى جنوب
روسيا تحديدا منطقه شمال القوقاز وتحديدا
البحر الاسود في منطقتي اناقه وطواب سي
حيث توجد
مراكز توزيع الغاز الى
التركي وبالتالي استهداف او لو نجحت بحسب
المعطيات الروسيه هذه العمليه لك كانت
تضررت شبكه خط انابيب مهمه فعليا هي التي
تنقل الان الكميات الاكبر من الغاز الروسي
الطبيعي الى تركيا ومن تركيا الى دول جنوب
اوروبا سيا ما هو ان روسيا كما ان اعلم
همم قدمت مشروعا وافقت عليه تركيا واجل
العمل عليه الان لجعل همم تركيا وتحديدا
نبتسم على الغربي من هذه الدوله همم مركز
لتوزيع الطاقه وبورصه لتحديد اسعار الطاقه
القادمه ليس فقط من روسيا وحتى من
اذربيجان ودول الاخرى همم الى القاره
الاوروبي وبالتالي
المقاطعه الروسيه كما جاء في الخبر تورط
مواطنين الروس حسب ما اعلنه جهاز الامن في
الديرالي الروسي
تفجير جسر عبد القادر من بين المتورطين في
هذه العمليه ايضا المواطنين رؤوس يجب ان
نفهم ايضا قضيه اساسيه وهي يعني تدخل
الكبير بين الروس الاوكرانيين من من جهه
همم هذا مهم في المعطى المعطى الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا هناك ايضا وجود كبير
لاوكرانيين داخل روسيا هناك همم القصر
المستعدون على ما يبدو على الاقل ان كان
من ناحيه الماديه او من ناحيه التضامنيه
ان يقدم على عمليات من هذا همم انه
وبالتالي في كل الحروف في كل النزاعات من
الطبيعي ان تكون هناك اختراقات من هذه
الدوله او الدوله الاخرى همم في قضايا
حساسه ولكن يعني بالنسبه لروسيا هذه قضيه
مهمه كما قلت في حال همم صدقه الروايه
الروسيه التي نشرتها اليوم ونشرت بعض
الصور كما شاهدنا قبل قليل همم جهاز من
الدوله
مش مدير مكتب الجزيره بالموسكو شكرا جزيلا
لك